si tu as besoin de quelque chose et que
tu vas trouver un des un des copains un
des gitans que tu connais enfin des gar
et que tu vas lui demander quelque chose
il te donne et et en contraire il est
encore plus content qu' t'a qui te qu'
t'a donné l'argent pour lui c'est
comment je Dirz moi c'est un
[Musique]
honneur porte de Saint-Ouin à Paris sur
terin VAG CR de HLM voici B mon copain
le
Gitan bon quel âge tu as 19 ans tu viens
de te marier
actuellement tu vis dans ta petite
voiture qui est là quand tu sors es ici
dans le terrain vague avec lesessort à
boudin là avec les les pneus
les grav et toute
[Musique]
l'histoireon
imagine tu vois l'appartement qui est
là-haut là ouais appartement avec les
rideaux bleus ouis bonattrape ça imagine
que c'est les clés de l'appartement
ouais si je te dis bon ben il est to il
est à toi si tu veux ouais qu'est-ce que
tu fais qu'est-ce que tu me
répondsen face tu vas dedans ou tu
restes dans ta petite voiture ah je dans
ma
voiture tu vivrais pas dans
l'appartement là
pourquoi ça me plaît pas de rester dans
une une maison et pourquoi ça te plaît
pas les CL en main tuas l'appartement là
tu vois l'antenne de télé au-dessus les
petits rideaux bleus le truc la porte tu
ouvres tu rentres tu es chez toi avec ta
femme tu as plus
ça non non ça plî pas une petite maison
tout seul sur un petit terrain
tranquille oui mais làdedans non ça me
plî pas tu resterais tout le temps ah
non pas tout le temps c'est tant que ça
pl puis après je m'en dirai combien de
temps tu rester à peu
près 3 4 mois
dedans c'est toutté je B' va et ta femme
tu crois qu'elle penserait comme toi ah
exement pareil tu es heureux de vivre
comme ça ah oui tu crois que je suis pas
heureux moi ah non non toi tu travailles
tous les jours les Gines vas-y le soir
tu rentres l matin tu REP vas-y toute la
journée comme ça avec nous on est
tranquille mon copain est un copain de
fraîche date 8 jours à peine jours
durant lesquels j'ai vécu avec les
gitans dans leur univers comme ou
presque c'est un univers où nous les
gadg n'avons rien à y faire en principe
un monde qui nous est fermé de temps en
temps les git nous regarde et nous juge
comme de temps à autre nous les
regardons et les jugons voici ce que
cela donne de leur côté encore une fois
les gadget c'est nous des
économiesieéconomie parce que nous on va
pas dire tiens aujourd'hui on va manger
un bifteak et fa faire attention que
demain on va manger un autre aujourd'hui
on mange TS on mange bien on fait pas la
semaine on fait
pas il y en a qui font leur compte quoi
nous on faut pas compte nous on mange on
mange il y a le moment où on devient
vieux quand même là ah oui alors là
qu'est-ce que tu fais quand tu es vieux
là tu as 19 ans c'est bon tu te dis
c'est un langage d'un gars de 19 ans ou
mais si je suis vieux j'ai des enfants
ouais il a mes enfants qui sont là
chez nous c'est comme ça les
enfants chez nous les vieux tu verras
jamais un vieux à la maison d'ire jamais
tu auras jamais un vieux qui se promène
sur la route qui mange pas chez nous les
vieux il sont dans la famille les vieux
sont plus respectés que les jeunes mais
tu as déjà vu les gadgets entre eux
comment ils font à ton avis comment ils
sont entre eux oh entre eux je je fa pas
vous dire comment ils sont parce que
j'ai jamais jamais comment j'ai jamais
VI avec les les
quandellement chez eux quoi j'ai jamais
vu comme ça j'ai jamais vu comment ils
sont entre eux quoi jamais j'ai vu ça
non mais tu dis bon j'ai Gadgé pour être
respecté faut avoir une maison faut
avoir une faut avoir de la richesse faut
avoir tout ça tu as l'impression que
c'est vrai ça ah ça ça c'est certain ça
qu'est-ce qu' faut dire ça par exemple
que j'ai vu plus j'ai des fois j'ai
entendis parler des gens voz celui-là
celui-là qui passe là c'est Monsieur tel
il a ça il a C il a ça il a ça campagne
il a plein de trucs quoi quand vous
voyez un petit garçon avec sa petite qu
chevau qui passe et puis qu'il est
emmerdé avec sa qu chevau toujours aprs
qu chevau celui-là il nous emmerde avec
celui-là
voilà si c'est monsieur qui passe oh là
là c'est Monsieur T qui passe et ça che
ça c'est jamais comme ça qu'il aille une
qu'il soit millionnaire qu'il soit comme
les autres ou qu' soit à plat
complètement c'est Monsieur c'est
Monsieur c'est tout et si tu es
malheureux par exemple si tu es si tu as
besoin de quelque chose et que tu vas
trouver un des un des copains des gitans
que tu connais enfin des gar et que tu
vas lui demander quelque chose il te
donne et en contraire il est encore plus
content qu'' qu' t'a donné de l'argent
pour lui c'est comment je vous dirais
moi c'est un honneur c'est un honneur
quoi pour lui de de donner un coup de
main chez nous c'est comme ça chez
nouson toi il t' arrivé quelque chose
toi é content je suis content j'ai fais
ça je fais ça fais ça nous quand on est
content nous on appelle tout le monde
manger bu toi tu fais pas ça tu es
content gardes pouri content à tout le
monde une communauté fermée avec ses
traditions ses lois s rit ainsi se
présente la
communautéitane entre cette communauté
et la NRE il existe une frontière il
nose aventure à nous qui croyons aux
lignes de la main plus que quoi que nous
en pensions nous fabriquons les voitures
et il les casse par contre il fabriquent
aujourd'hui la chaudronnerie que
certains de nos antiquir vendent au prix
des souvenirs du passé de notre passé
ils stationnent là où nos lois leur
interdisent le stationnement et nos
techniques industrielles celles de la
dorure sur métal par exemple prennent
entre leurs mains des allures d'alchimie
n'est-ce pas monsieur deéter
expliquez-moi donc votre procédé secret
alors j'ai préparé l'or dans ma cuvette
je mets produit chimiquees que c'est
très ordinaire d'ailleurs je peux vous
dire le nom de ce que c'est c'est un
liquide acide chlorhydrique
22° que je compose dans mon ma cuhette
de d'or et je mets ensuite mélange acide
nutrique 40 % d'acide nutrique
ordinaire pas besoin de mettre de
produit spécialisé dans parce que vous
avez les mêm produit qui coût très
cher produit acide NRI qui coûte environ
1800 francs le litre ce produit d'acide
nrique que j'emploie ça coûte 90
francs vous avez desend AC la
police beaucoup Monsieur beaucoup
comment ça se
passe qu'est-ce que voulezv que je vous
dis làd monsieur moi je trouve de mon
côté en étant français en étant
français obéir la France je suis
français tous mes enfants sont français
ils ont fait le service
militaire on peut pas être plus français
on est né en France et faire le service
militaire on est des bon français et
bien tout ce qu'on est bon franç
et ben on n' même pas le droit de rester
sur des gadous c'est pas de vous dire
sur la route dans en
embrouiller la route ou quelque chose
sur des Gou on n même pas le droit de
rester sur les Gadou on
est on
est sur les Gadou et puis viennent à
minuit 2h du matin il nous casse nos
fenêtres ils cassent les crures ils
rentent dans les voitures ils nous
prennent du bois deelit tout nu et il
nous mettent dans leur camion tout nu et
nous ramène là-bas vers leur chef et
c'est les femmes derrière qui nous
amènent nos effets pour
s'habiller moi je ne vois pas moi je ne
vois pas par qu les lois qui peuvent
faire ça c'est très mal moi je trouve
que c'est très mal j'ai demandé alors
chef si c'est eux qui donnent le droit
comme ça et ils m'ont dit que oui c'est
eux qui donnent le droit comme ça ils
disent encore vous avez l'air de porter
plainte non Monsieur le Chef mais je
voudrais savoir si c'est vous qu' leur
donner le droit ils m'ont dit oui et
taisez-vous alors si c'est vous j'ai
plus rien à dire est-ce qu'il expliquer
pourquoi pour pas rester dans la scène
je vous ai dit de aucune voiture resté
dans la
scène combien y a-t-il de Git en France
et bien monsieur vous me posez une
question qui est très paradoxale il est
difficile de recenser les
hondelles nous avons essayé par deux
fois en 60 et en 61 et nous arrivons
approximativement à considérer qu'ils
sont au moins 50000 et au plus
70000 mais je ne répond rien n'est-ce
pas il y a certainement des chiffres
ou gonflés ou sous-estimés ils sont très
fluides cet interdiction de
stationnement ça se présente comment en
fait sur le plan du territoire français
et bien monsieur je vous répondrai d'une
façon apparemment badine parce que je ne
voudrais pas dramatiser cette
conversation il serait facile de la
dramatiser j'aime mieux vous répondre
par une apparente
plaisanterie comment ça se résout et
bien chacun dit il aller chez l'autre et
de département à département on se les
renvoie de commune à commune et n'alllez
pas croire pour autant que les préfets
soient des hommes méchants et que les
maires nai pas bon cœur mais n'est-ce
pas il y a une espèce d'opinion sourde
de sens commun attardé qui fait que le
fond de population qui ne pense pas la
chose est incommodé de les voir là
qu'est-ce qui vous attire à Paris
l'hiver euh sais pas c'est comme si que
ça serait notre maison c'est un point
d'attache tous les hivers on vient ici
donc on serait à 1000 km 2000 km l'hiver
octobre novembre nous sommes ici on
revient
ici bon alors quand vous arrivez à Paris
vous allez où quand on VI à Paris bah on
fait les portes porte de Montreuil PORTE
DE cliancour PORTE DE saint-toin PORTE
DE montmart Place Balard porte devant
tout ça on fait tout les portes tout le
tour de Paris bon c'est-à-dire vous
restez combien de temps à peu près sur
un sur un sur une des portes sur une des
portes oh alors là des fois on peut
rester 1 heure comme des fois on peut
rester 2 jours comme des fois on peut
rester 3 jours des fois une journée des
fois 4 jours mais avec des embêtements
alors continuellement bon mais alors
quelle est la solution à ça vous avez
bien dû penser à une solution qu'est-ce
que vous-ce que vous voyez nous avons
pensé déjà à ça n'est-ce pas plusieurs
on a parlé de ça si on pourrait trouver
par exemple un terrain un grand terrain
qui a le nécessaire n'est-ce pas qui a
ce qu'il faut quoi puis l'eau
principalement les
WC qui on puisse envoyer nos enfants à
l'école qu'on puisse travailler
tranquillement n'est-ce pas même en
payant une somme n'importe quelle somme
on serait content de rester au moins on
saurait qu'on pourrait travailler qu'on
peut rester sur
place après 8 jours de cette vie passée
avec les gitans je suis rentré chez les
gadget chez moi plus dépaysés Queau
retour d'un reportage au bout du monde
pourtant je n'avais rien fait d' que de
tourner autour de Paris d'une
interdiction de stationner à
[Musique]
l'autre depuis la guerre de 100 ans les
gitans sillonnent les routes de France
assurant une permanence de leur mode de
vie et de leur race au-delà de tous les
régimes de toutes les lois de toutes les
répressions dont la plus féroce remonte
à la dernière guerre durant laquelle ils
furent décimés dans les camps de
concentration il est aisé de faire comme
s'il n'existait pas il suffit de décider
qu'ils iront stationner
ailleurs il est simple de décréter
qu'ils n'ont qu'à faire comme nous mais
nous savons depuis un certain temps que
l'intégration qu'elle soit sociale
politique ou racial et parfois un
redoutable piège que nous tend la
facilité il est commode enfin de
s'apitoyer sur leur sort mais les gitans
rejettent et méprisent la pitié des
gadgets
quelle différence y a-t-il donc entre
eux et nous j'ai tout au long de mon
séjour inlassablement posé la question
quelle différence y y a-t-il entre une
minorité cohérente et la majorité qui
l'accueille c'est l'éternelle
question quelle différence entre vous et
moi je peux pas vous le
dire que moi qu'est-ce que je vouux vous
dire vous vous êtes un gadoo et puis moi
j'en suis pas et vous vous allez me dire
qu'est-ce que c'est un gadoo un homme je
suis un
homme voilà on peut devenir copain mais
on sera jamais comme ça jamais comme ça
tuir grand
ami dans ma tête ça sera toi tu seras
toujours c'est comme ça chez
N pour moi tu vois tu peux devenir mon
plus grand copain et dans ma tête tu
seras pas un
gitan ça
mon ça
m si je suis un gant pour tout le monde
pour tous les
[Musique]
suis suis s s ça pe pas changer avant ça
fa 10 ans que j'étais
là-bas pour les gens il m'app par mon
nom sa que je suis et quand vous demandz
quelque chosevez aller voir les G et
pourant ça fait 10 ans qu'on était
làbas tu crois que les
ça
sais que c'est pas marrant ce que tu
dis et oui Ballo voilà et le gadoo que
je suis te salue bien mais cela dit
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
[Musique]
continue